[Applaus]
[Musik]
Elvan ist ein zumindest für
Ostasiatische Verhältnisse eher kleines
Land mit rund 23 Millionen Einwohner
aber während der letzten sieben
Jahrzehnte wurde es immer wieder zu
einem Brennpunkt der internationalen
Politik
der offizielle Name von Taiwan
sondern
das liegt daran dass
jede
nach der Revolution
Revolution
die Chinesen also ihre Muschi und
ersetzen sie durch eine Republik doch
das war nicht das Ende der Geschichte
später fielen die
reichsten und mächtigsten Teil des
Landes für mehrere Jahrzehnte unter ihre
Kontrolle zu japanische Besatzung gab es
in China zwei große
Widerstandsbewegungen die Kommunistische
Partei Chinas
und die
republikanische
Kräfte
konzentrieren Sie sich auf den Kampf
gegen die japanischen
operierten zu diesem Zweck
als jedoch am Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs Japan kapitulierte und sich
zurückzog brachte erinner chinesische
Machtkampf wieder voll aus dieser
brutalen Bürgerkrieg tobte bis ins Jahr
1949 null sicherlich schon wer gewonnen
hat Magellan ist die kommunistische
Volksrepublik auf dem chinesischen
Festland zu errichten während die
Anführer der Republikaner und die Reste
ihrer Armee auf die Insel Formosa flohen
und dort ihren eigenen chinesischen
Staat gründeten
und dieser Staat war der legitime
Rechtsnachfolge der 1912 gegründeten
Ersten Republik in ganz hier
aus diesem Grund erkannten ihn auch
viele Länder für mehr als 30 Jahre alt
legitime Regierung ganz China Sun für
sie war das Regime aus nichts anderes
als ein Besatzungsregime dass das
chinesische Festland unrechtmäßig
besetzt hielt und diesmal natürlich auch
das traditionelle narrativ der
taiwanesischen Regierung
aber Vorsicht bei der republikanische
Regierung in Taiwan konnte man damals
auch nicht gerade von Demokraten
sprechen nein in Teil waren gab es lange
eine sehr starke Diktatur unter der
Kontrolle von Chiang Kai-shek bis 996
fanden dort keine demokratischen Wahlen
statt doch dank ihres Bundes ist mit den
USA die Republik China das heißt Taiwan
bis 1971 den chinesischen Witz bei den
Vereinten Nationen und die von Mao
Tse-tung gegründete und kontrolliert der
Volksrepublik ging leer ausgehen
denn beide starten erhoben Anspruch auf
das Recht international alleinvertretung
Gesamtjahr diese Doktrin wird als ein
China Politik bezeichnet und Peking
verfolgt sie bis heute ab 1971 begann
sich jedoch alles zu ändern in jedem
Jahr verlor Taiwan sein sitzt bei der
UNO an die Volksrepublik China ein
Land kann halt nur einen Sitz bei der
UNO innehaben und wenn es zwei Regierung
gibt die sich für legitim halten dann
muss man sich für die eine oder die
andere entscheiden und darin liegt das
Problem Taiwan hat sich damals nicht als
weiteres unabhängiges Land betrachtet
sondern als das legitime einzige China
was für ein Caps
[Musik]
dabei gibt es bei Spiele solcher
Teilungen ja öfter z.b. zwischen der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und der DDR
und dieser habe sich irgendwann
gegenseitig als souveräne Staaten
anerkannt es gab keine brutale ein
Deutschlandpolitik die Chinesen stellen
die Welt jedoch vor ein entweder oder
Wahl ja und mit der international
Anerkennung und den globalen Einfluss
Timer ging es ab 1971 bergab da es immer
mehr starten wichtig war Beziehungen zum
größeren Festlandchina aufzubauen heute
ist der Einfluss Peking so groß dass die
meisten auch demokratischen Länder ganz
nach dessen Pfeife tanzen wenn es um die
Verachtung gegenüber Taiwan geht sogar
in der Korona Krise zeigte sich das für
viele Regierungen Machtpolitik weit
wichtiger ist als die Welt Gesundheit
denn obwohl Teil waren mittlerweile eine
stabile Demokratie ist und als erstes
Land vor Corona gewarnt hat wird es z.b.
von Deutschland weitgehend ignoriert
China hingegen ist eine Diktatur hat die
Epidemie lange verputzt und wird dafür
auch noch belohnt z.b. durch die
Mitgliedsländer der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO die
meisten wollten sich den Druck Pekings
und Lidl ist abteiwaren als Mitglied
aufzunehmen trotz seiner
offensichtlichen Erfolge bei der
Bewältigung der Coroner Krise welche
dort Gegensatz zu Festlandchina ohne
drakonische Einschränkungen der
Menschenrechte möglich war
[Musik]
die Weigerung der WHO Taiwan aufzunehmen
ist ein Problem für die ganze Welt denn
Taiwan ist das erste Land gewesen das
auf die Mensch zu Mensch Übertragung des
neuen Coronavirus hingewiesen hat
während Peking damals noch alles unter
den Tisch kehren wollte vor diesem
Hintergrund die Unterstützung für Taiwan
viele Regierungen fordern für das Land
in der BHA also der Versammlung der WHO
zumindest einen Beobachterstatus die USA
Kanada Australien und Neuseeland setzen
sich dafür ein und mehr als 100
geordnete des EU Parlaments und die
Bundestagsabgeordneten in einen offenen
Brief an die Gesundheitsminister der 27
EU-Staaten die Einladung des
taiwanesischen Gesundheitsministers zu
der Versammlung
gefordert aber kein europäischer
Außenminister hat sich vor großem
Publikum Taiwans Beobachterstatus
ausgesprochen zu groß ist die Angst vor
chinesischer Vergeltung in einem
früheren Video haben wir euch bereits
darüber erzählt auf welche Weise Peking
The Who unterwandert und wie diese immer
mehr Heide Kommunistischen Partei Chinas
wird die WHO Beweis diesen Verdacht
natürlich von ich es gibt dir doch einen
ziemlichen bestes Indiz dass dieser
Verdacht sehr angebracht ist
[Musik]
von 2009 bis 2016 hatte Teil war nämlich
bereits einen Beobachterstatus in der
WHO doch damals stellte die momentan die
Regierung in Taipei recording ist eine
taiwanesische Partei die Peking sehr
nahe steht seit 2016 aber regiert Teil
waren die DTP einer Partei die in Chinas
Augen aus einer Hand voll von
Separatisten besteht China bestraft also
die Bürger Taiwan dafür dass sie in
einer demokratischen Wahl für die ddp
gestimmt haben und die WHO lässt sich
dafür einfach so instrumentalisiert ja
nicht besonders gut aus für den kleinen
demokratischen David der vom
kommunistischen Goliath an die Wand
gedrückt wird wo es nur geht wie aber
konnte es nur soweit kommen was geschah
mit den Timer anders als von allen
westlichen Großmächten voll anerkannt
wurde wird aus Taiwan werden jetzt da
rot China zu einer Supermacht geworden
ist und was noch wichtiger ist welche
Entwicklung können wir nach den enormen
Protest in Hongkong und den jüngsten
Präsidentschaftswahlen vom Januar 2020
in Taiwan erwarten sehen wir uns das
alles mal aus der Nähe an
[Musik]
zum legitimen Erben zum politischen
Ärgernis wie gesagt die Regierung Teil
war stellte sie jahrelang für die
meisten Länder der souveränen Vertreter
der chinesischen Nation da
doch der zunehmende Einfluss der
Volksrepublik zusammen mit ihrem
wirtschaftlichen Erwachen drehte den
Spieß nach Unna um Taiwan begann die
Anerkennung fast aller Länder zu
verlieren mit einigen wenigen Ausnahmen
sogar die Vereinigten Staaten Taiwan
wichtigster Verbündeter wechselten
loseblatt 79 oder der Regierung für die
carta offizielle Seite gegenwärtig
erkennen neben dem Vatikan nur 14 kleine
Länder die Republik China als gültigen
Vertreter hinaus an
diese Situation und die Tatsache dass
selbst die engsten Verbündeten Taiwan
sie nicht mehr offiziell anerkennen
veranlasse die Inselregierung anfangen
der 1990 er Jahre ihren Anspruch als
rechtmäßigen Alleinvertreter China
aufzugeben
seither hat sich Taiwan einer Strategie
zugewandt die immer deutlicher wird und
im Laufe der Zeit immer mehr
Unterstützung findet nicht als die
Republik China sondern uralt Taiwan
anerkannt zu werden
angesichts der bisherigen Geschichte
ergibt das durchaus Sinn die Taiwaner
verstehen nur allzu gut dass die
politischen sozialen wirtschaftlichen
und demokratischen Maßnahmen die sie im
Laufe der Jahre auf der Insel ergriffen
haben zu einer großen Kluft zwischen der
Insel und dem chinesischen Festland
geführt haben
der Lebensstil das politische System und
die Gesellschaft in Taiwan unterscheiden
sich auf Kasse Weise von dem was in der
Volksmusik China unter der Diktatur der
Kommunistischen Partei vor sich geht und
die derzeitige Regierung Taiwans hat
begriffen dass diese gesellschaftlichen
Unterschiede mittlerweile unüberwindbar
sind und eine Wiedervereinigung mit dem
chinesischen Festland vollkommen
unrealistisch wäre es hatte sich
schlicht und einfach um zwei vollkommen
verschiedenen einander im Grunde fremde
Länder Chinas Unterdrückung Taiwans auf
der internationalen Bühne kann weder die
unbestreitbare Tatsache der Existenz
Taiwan ändern noch kann die das
taiwanesische Volk dazu zwingen seine
demokratische und frei Lebensweise
aufzugeben Taiwan Außenministerium der
biblischen Flüchtlinge deren Nachkommen
heute etwa 14 Prozent der Bevölkerung
haben Sie innerhalb weniger Jahrzehnte
eine neue Nation ein eigenständiges Volk
mit ureigenen Charakteristika geschaffen
dabei bestand auffordern Ankunft fast
die ganze Bevölkerung der Insel wie die
des Festlands aus Hand lesen und genau
diese Idee einer eigenen nationalen
Identität die vollkommen losgelöst und
unheimlich ist vom Rest Chinas ist die
Linie welcher Zeit irgendwann von der
Demokratischen Fortschrittspartei
verteidigt aber
[Musik]
wartet mal einen Moment denn die Sache
hat einen Haken diese besondere Version
wird nicht von allen geteilt die
Komintern eine noch immer wichtige
Parteien Taiwan verträgt eine ganz
andere Position engere Beziehungen und
Verständigung mit dem chinesischen
Regime aber Moment mal sagte ich gerade
Kuomintang
dann haben sag uns doch was
[Musik]
genau
ist die Partei die von den
nationalistischen Anführer der erste
chinesische Republik gegründet wurde
gegen die kommunistische Revolution und
das heutige Taiwan könnten und auch wenn
es unglaublich klingt die Partei die
eins mit dem kommunistischen Regime bis
aufs Messer verfeindet war jetzt für die
Freundschaften in
einer Kombination aus Nationalismus
Sozialismus also das kennen wir doch
irgendwoher und als wenn das nicht genug
wäre gesellt sich zu diesen netten
Ideologie noch eine andere Schule Zutat
Geld unglaublich viel Geld spielt in
dieser Geschichte eine entscheidende
Rolle damit nicht nur einfach Geld aus
Bestechung und Korruption nein es geht
darum ordentlichen abzuschneiden von der
die
sich mittlerweile auf dem chinesischen
Festland
genau
entscheiden würdest du dich entscheiden
wenn du die Wahl hättest
Alter des Landes zu kämpfen und die
lukrativen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen zur
Supermacht China aufs Spiel zu setzen
oder einen Weg der Verständigung mit
Peking einschlagen diese Frage ist alles
andere als trivial es ist die große
Frage die sich alle in Taiwan stellen
und kollektiv bei jeder Parlamentswahl
beantworten müssen
bevor wir aber weiter machen gibt es
eine Frage die wir beantworten müssen
das nach und nach immer mehr
und ist nicht mehr als die Vertreter
für Taiwan ein Spießrutenlauf
offiziellen diplomatischen Beziehungen
mit Aufdruck
viele Staaten erkennen aber die
Souveränität und weiterhin an ehemaligen
Botschaften sind zu Wirtschafts und
Kulturbüro geworden die defacto auch als
Botschaften
[Musik]
Verfügung gestellt wurden und
international
die große Verjüngung des chinesischen
Volkes in Peking
seit Jahren mit verschiedenen
[Musik]
Moment
allein
so hat der Volksrepublik China über
Taiwan anzuerkennen
Veränderungen auf diplomatischem Felsen
in der Tat eine Herausforderung aber
Taiwan hat immer noch viele Freunde in
der ganzen Welt die bereit sind uns zur
Seite zu stehen und wir sind nicht
allein Taiwans präsent zeigen wenn die
Regierung Taiwans hat sich also für eine
Strategie der Differenzierung
entschieden wir haben nichts mit Tina zu
tun wir sind wir haben nicht die Absicht
über jemand anderen als und selbst zu
herrschen und belasten auch nicht zu
dass ein anderer über uns herrscht die
ist die Botschaft von Präsident Zeit und
mit dieser hat er bei den taiwanesischen
wlan ein tiefen Eindruck hinterlassen
bei den nächsten Präsidentschaftswahlen
bei der Sieg Zeiss überwältigend verteil
erhielt 58% der Stimmen das waren fast
20% mehr als die Formen kann dies war
also viel mehr als ein einfacher Sieg
zeige langsam mit dem Fremden in den
Boden zu haben und wie mit einer
Dampfwalze und einen dicken Asphalt
nicht platt zu machen
und damit mein wenn ich nur die fünfte
Kolonne PGP sonst direkt gemacht habe in
Peking das folgende müsst ihr euch mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen
[Musik]
Taiwan Thermometer des chinesischen
Expansion ist
die Wahl in Taiwan von Januar 2020 waren
ein gewaltiger demokratischer Schlag ins
Gesicht des autokratischen Regimes in
Peking
diese Abstimmung Strecken Taiwanesen
einen gewaltigen Stinkefinger in
Richtung Peking aus wenn die dortigen
Kommunisten hatten sie vor der Wahl
ständig und eindringlich gewarnt ja
eigentlich direkt schlimme Konsequenzen
angedroht falls die Mehrheit der Wähler
für den Demokraten stimmen sollte aber
bei all dem was ich gerade in Hugo
spielen konnten die Taiwanesen den
wahren Charakter der roten Bestie klarer
erkennen den die die ständige
Einmischung Pekings in die
Angelegenheiten Hongkongs die Verletzung
des Sonderstatus der Stadt um diese
Unterdrückung der Proteste für Freiheit
und Demokratie haben dazu geführt dass
die Taiwanesen das wenige vertrauen dass
sie in rot hinein auch hatten verloren
haben deshalb haben sie dekorieren Kurs
mit Peking abgestraft einen Kuschelkurs
der angeblich zu größerer
wirtschaftlicher Prosperität führen
würde das heißt zu chinesischen Geld
angeblich auch zu mehr Frieden in der
Region mich einer Verringerung des
Einflusses der Vereinigten Staaten was
das taiwanesische voll von solchen
Versprechen Hey hat sich jetzt jedoch
eindeutig gezeigt der von Simon erzielte
Erdrutsch von fast 20 Prozentpunkten
stellt den triumphalen Wahlsieg seit
Bestehen des Landes da die Ergebnisse
dieser Wahl haben einen noch
weiterreichende Bedeutung sie haben
gezeigt dass das taiwanesische Volk noch
entschlossener und lauter widersprechen
wird wenn unsere Souveränität bedroht
ist Taiwans Präsident Zeit ingman zeigte
sich die Angst das aber lesen vor dem
Freiheitsverlust durch mehr Einfluss aus
Peking zunutze machen die jungen
Menschen in Hongkong haben ihr Lieben
eingesetzt aber auch ihr Blut und ihre
Tränen vergossen um uns zu zeigen dass
ein Land zwei Systeme nicht funktioniert
lass uns morgen unseren jungen Menschen
in Taiwan zeigen dass die Werte von
Demokratie und Freiheit alle
Schwierigkeiten überwinden werden
Taiwans Präsident Zeit im Moment
Schwierigkeiten von dem Zeit spricht
sind die internationale politische
Isolation und der Verlust von
Investitionen
aber der rote Riese ist fest
entschlossen Taipei noch weiter zu
isolieren damit so der Wirtschaft
Taiwans die Luft abgedreht und der
Inselstaat zum Einlenken gezogen werden
wenn er seinen Lebensstandard
aufrechterhalten möchte und um dies zu
erreichen schaut Peking keinerlei und
Kosten wir mittlerweile wisst gibt es
nur noch sehr wenige Länder die Taiwan
offiziell als legitime Regierung Chinas
anerkennen es handelt sich hierbei um 14
Uhr international unbedeutende kleine
Staaten gibt's nur Spiel HIT und
Guatemala aber selbst hier lässt Peking
nicht locker die zwei jüngsten Beispiele
sind zwei winzige Länder die Taiwan noch
vor kurzem als legitimen Regierung hier
das anerkannt haben die Salomonen und
Kiribati China den seinen Einfluss im
Pazifik aus während die Salomon-Inseln
mit Taiwan brechen Rekorde bei wann
verliert einem weiteren Verbündeten
Kiribati bricht Beziehungen ab BBC2
kleine Inselgruppe im Pazifik die für
die Vereinigten Staaten bei der
Eindämmung der chinesischen
Expansionsbestrebungen von entscheidende
Bedeutung hätten sein können doch
schalte ich die Waagschale mehr denn je
in Richtung Peking schneiden
und in 14 Länder die Taiwan anerkennen
bleiben nur vier im südpazifischen Raum
übrig die Taiwan anerkennen oder nicht
ist ein implizites Barometer dafür ob
sie sich er gegenüber den Vereinigten
Staaten oder gegenüber China loyal sein
und das Bild was sich daraus ergibt ist
erschreckend die laxe Haltung der
Vereinigten Staaten in den letzten
Jahrzehnten und die Macht chinesischen
Geldes haben in diesem Teil der Welt
dafür gesorgt dass ich Ina weder kriege
noch eine große Kriegsbeute benötigte um
sich die Kontrolle über diese für den
Welthandel sehr wichtigen Meeresregionen
zu sichern und Taiwan dass sich für
weitere vier Jahre für die
Unabhängigkeitsbewegung entschieden hat
darf nicht nur auf eine derart
unterkühlte Beziehung mit Peking
vorbereiten dass in der Nordpol für die
Toten vorkommende apropos diplomatische
Beziehungen zwischen China und Taiwan
eigentlich können wir ja meistens nur
über das Blockieren von
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen sprechen
[Musik]
und das ist die Herausforderung vor der
Präsident Zeit steht dann wird mir
ging's nicht sowohl aktiv als ob sie für
etwas eingesetzt hat dann ist es die
Abschaffung der Unabhängigkeit Taiwans
Chinas Kommunisten werden diese nie und
nimmer tolerieren und Taiwan hat sich
nun entschieden die Intoleranz so
konsequent die Stirn zu bieten die noch
nie zuvor wir lehnen das Modell ein Land
zwei Systeme ab wir chatten den
Lebensstil der Demokratie und wir
verteidigen unsere Souveränität
Simon es bleibt also spannend und uns
bleibt ist nur euch nach eurer Meinung
zu fragen wenn ihr in Taiwan Werft wen
würdet ihr wählen für was würdet ihr
euch entscheiden politische und
gesellschaftliche Freiheiten oder das
Geld aus China glaubt ihr dass Taiwan
auch ohne das Festland weiter wachsen
und sich entwickeln kann wie immer sind
wir auf eure Kommentare und Meinungen
gespannt und vergiss bitte nicht dass
wir jede Woche neue Videos hochladen
verpasst also keines unserer Update
abonniert unseren Kanal und klickt auch
auf das Klingel Symbol vom rechtzeitig
wir hoffen dass euch dieses Video etwas
gebracht hat falls ja gib uns einen
Daumen hoch und unterstütze uns indem du
dieses Video mit deinen Freunden teilst
mach's gut und bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]